Let's do some more problems
involving Newton's laws.
OK, so this problem that I am
picking from-- I think it's
from Oregon University.
It's zebu.uoregan.edu.
I want to give them credit
for their problem.
Let's see, let me draw-- this
is going to be the ground.
And then the problem says
that I have a train--
so this is a train.
Try my best to draw a train.
Something like that.
And there's smoke coming out.
And it says that the
train of mass 6.84.
So let's say the mass of the
train is 6.84 times 10 to the
sixth kilograms. That's the
mass of this train.
Is moving at a speed of 80
kilometers per hour.
So it's velocity, we could say
it's initial velocity because
I think it's going to ask me
what happens to its velocity.
So its initial velocity
is equal to 80
kilometers per hour.
So it's going this way at
80 kilometers per hour.
The brakes, which produce a net
backward force of-- so the
brakes are going to pull
backwards-- a net backward
force of-- so force is equal
to 1.93 times 10
to the sixth Newtons.
That's 1.93 times 10 to
the sixth Newtons.
I know it looks a little
bit messy.
The brakes are going to be
applied for 25 seconds.
I'll say force sub b or the
force of the brakes is 1.93
times 10 to the sixth Newtons.
And then, they will be applied
for 25 seconds.
So the first question to
ask is, what is the new
speed of the train?
So what is the speed of the
train after the brakes are
applied for 25 seconds?
Well, all we have to figure out
is how fast is the train
decelerating?
Or what rate of deceleration
does this
backward force create?
So we just go back
to our basics.
Let me switch colors because
this red's getting a little
monotonous.
Force is equal to mass
times acceleration.
Probably the easiest formula
ever to memorize.
And what's the backward force?
The backward force is 1.93
times 10 to the sixth.
And that equals mass
times acceleration.
What's the mass?
Mass is right here.
That's a decimal.
6.84 times 10 to the sixth
times the acceleration.
And acceleration is what we're
trying to figure out.
And remember, if the force is
pulling back, then of course,
the acceleration is also
going to be backwards.
Or it's going to essentially,
slow down the train.
I know this is very messy, but
let's just divide-- well, we
could divide both sides by 10 to
the sixth just to get that
out of the way.
That simplifies things
a little bit.
And then we're left with
the acceleration.
I'm just flipping both sides
of this equation.
Acceleration is equal to 1.93
divided by 6.84. soon.
And this is going to be given in
meters per second squared.
And I just want to make sure
I got my units right.
Because this number here, the
mass was in kilograms. And
then the force was
given in units.
So the acceleration will be in
meters per second squared.
And let's get the handy
calculator here because this
looks-- I don't want to waste
your time reviewing how to
divide decimals.
Although, that might
not be a bad
review; most people forget.
1.93 divided by 6.-- whoops.
I think I messed up.
Let me see.
1.93 divided by 6.84 is 0.282.
So its acceleration equals-- is
equal to 0.28-- let's just
say 282 meters per
second squared.
And so how fast is the
train going to be
going after 25 seconds?
So what's the change
in velocity?
Well the change in velocity
is equal to
acceleration times time.
And if we take its velocity as
a positive number, then its
acceleration will be a negative
number, right?
Because it's going to be going
in the opposite direction.
Could have done it the
other way around.
So the change in velocity is
going to be equal to this
minus 0.282 meters per
second squared.
I won't write the units
here because I'm
running out of space.
Minus 0.282 meters per second
squared times 25 seconds.
Let's get the calculator
back here.
Where'd it go?
There it is.
OK.
So now we want to multiply that
number we just figured
out times 25.
Equals 7.05.
So the change in velocity
is equal to minus
7.05 meters per second.
OK, so let's see what's
going on.
The initial speed of the train
is 80 kilometers per hour.
But we have the change
in velocity given
in meters per second.
So we can either change this
change in velocity to
kilometers per hour, or we could
go the other way around
and do the- or change the
kilometers per hour into
meters per second.
I don't know, let's change the
meters per second into
kilometers per hour.
So there are how many meters--
so it'll be minus 7.05.
And how many meters are
there in a kilometer?
Well there are a thousand
meters in a kilometer.
So it's going to be going that
number divided by a thousand
kilometers.
And if this is a little
confusing, I'm skipping a
couple of steps.
You might want to review the
video on unit conversion.
And then, this is meters per
second, but we want to get
kilometers per hour.
How may seconds are
there in an hour?
There are 3,600.
right?
So it'll go 3,600 times as
far in an hour as it
does it in a second.
Times 3,600.
So we can get rid of two 0's
here and two 0's here.
So it's essentially going
to be 7.05 you times 36.
I just got rid of the 0's.
I'll write the 0's there, just
so you don't get confused.
Divided by a thousand.
1, 2, 3.
Equals 25.39 kilometers
per hour.
So I'll just round.
25 kilometers per hour.
So the change in velocity is
minus 25 kilometers per hour.
What's the change velocity?
If it was starting off at 80
kilometers and then the change
in velocity is minus 25, what's
its new velocity?
Well it's going to be 80 minus
25, the initial velocity minus
the change in velocity.
Or plus the change in velocity
depending on how you view that
negative number.
So 80 minus 25.
So we could say the final
velocity is going to be 80
minus 25 is 55 kilometers
per hour.
Now the second part of this
question is, how far has the
train traveled in this time?
So essentially, how long-- how
far does the train go as it
brakes from 80 kilometers
per hour to 55
kilometers per hour?
Well, all we have to figure out
is the average velocity
and then multiply that
times the time.
So what's the average
velocity here?
Well actually, let me just clear
this because I think
it's getting-- you don't need
a drawing of a train.
Let's see if I remember my-- so
the initial velocity was 80
kilometers per hour.
Final velocity is 55 kilometers
per hour.
So the average velocity is going
to be 80 plus 55 over 2,
which is, what?
67 and 1/2, something
like that.
67 and 1/2 kilometers
per hour.
And then if we want to figure
out the total distance it
travels, distance is equal to
average velocity times time.
The average velocity?
Well, we have the time
in seconds, right?
So we have 25 seconds here.
But this is given in kilometers
per hour.
So we want to convert this into,
maybe meters per second.
So what we do is take
the 67.5, it's going
to go times a thousand.
that's.
How many meters it's
going to go.
And then in a second it's going
to go 1/3,600 of that.
So let's see what
that gives us.
67.5 times 1,000 divided
by 3,600.
18.75.
That's the meters per second.
That's the average velocity
in meters per second.
And we go for 25 seconds, so
what does that give us?
Times 25 equals 468 meters.
468.75 meters.
That's how far it traveled
just to brake from 80
kilometers per hour to 55
kilometers per hour.
And it took 25 seconds.
Hopefully I haven't confused
you too much.
See